One of the major functions of the immune system is not defense,
but managing the Microbiota and the Microbiota are then co evolving with their
management by the immune system,
just as they co evolve with the defense function of the immune system.
This happens particularly in the gut and on the skin.
Yeah,
and we also can see what would happen if there had not been any coevolution by
considering the example of render pest.
Yeah,
so our commensal Microbiota is immense.
Each of us contains over a thousand species of bacteria and an unknown and
astronomically large number of viruses.
These microorganisms do not normally cause disease in a healthy host.
Some of them can do so in an immunocompromised host if they change niche.
Okay.
Pathogens represent only a tiny fraction of the microbes that colonizers
and many of the commensal microbes are present providing us with essential
benefits.
They produce vitamins,
they help us digest complex polysaccharides.
They detoxify harmful chemicals,
they compete with pathogens for intestinal niches,
and they provide the stimulation necessary for proper maturation of the immune
system.
Yeah,
so how are they managed?
Okay.
They're managed by our immune system.
We can see this in immunocompromised individuals who suffer from infections that
are commonly caused by the same microorganisms that are normally harmless in
immune confident people.
Okay.
The immune system is those operating both remove pathogens but also to maintain
host microbe homeostasis.
Okay.
It does.
So by controlling the growth and invasion of commensal microbes that can cause
disease in immune in immunocompromised states,
these are the opportunistic or endogenous pathogens.
Okay.
The action is actually most intense at epethelial interfaces and the epithelium
Mucosa.
See where our need for access,
access to oxygen and the nutrients opens up doors that microbes can enter.
So that is where the management needs to be the most careful.
Okay.
We do produce some natural probiotics to help manage the Microbiota.
Human milk oligosaccharides are the third most abundant component of breast
milk.
When bifidobacterium longum infanticide has grown on human milk
oligosaccharides,
it adheres better the human intestinal epilepsy,
legal sales,
and there it induces greater expression of anti inflammatory cytokine aisle 10
and junctional adhesion molecules then do control strains that are grown on
lactose.
So the kind of illegal saccharide provided by human breast milk appears to have
been designed by evolution specifically to promote the growth of a particular
member of the Microbiota.
Those of the host is encouraging the colonization of infant gut by a beneficial
bacteria.
Let's take a look at the gut ecosystem.
In this left panel we have a healthy gut environment and in the right panel we
have an altered gut environment and the healthy gut environment.
Out in the gut lumen we have a mixture of peacekeeping bacteria and pathogens.
We have a healthy epithelial barrier and behind that epithelial barrier we have
t-cells,
various types,
and we have then the Lamin appropriate,
which is also a mechanical barrier and an altered gut environment.
We have a damaged epithelial barrier that allows increased bacterial adherence
and penetration because normally the bacteria can't get through the mucus to get
that close to the epithelium.
And if the bacteria you can get through the barrier,
they produce back pathological inflammation.
So in the healthy gut,
the immune system is maintaining the microbes as commensals out in the lumen and
in the altered gut.
The defenses have been breached.
And Immune activation leads to inflammation and infection can follow both genes
and environment are contributing to this.
So there are genes where mutations in particular receptors such as the nod
receptor,
uh,
make this kind of breaching of the barrier more likely and stress Diet and uh,
vaccines possibly.
And then,
uh,
infections are all things that can contribute as well.
So it's a gene environment interaction.
Similarly with the skin
and the healthy skin ecosystem,
we have the epidermis.
Of course there are things that breached the epidermis.
There are sweat glands and hair follicles.
So those are paths of entry living on the epidermis or fungi,
bacteria and viruses that are also living in the hair follicles.
They are communicating below the,
below the epidermis and Dermis with macrophages and with dendritic cells.
And these are sending out signals which are generating antimicrobial defenses.
So there are anti microbial peptides that are also out there on the surface of
the skin that are being made by the immune system.
Okay.
So in the healthy skin,
the Microbiota are in conversation with the immune system?
Yeah,
they promote immunity by activating lymphocytes.
And to visualize the scale of this,
the healthy human skin contains about 20 billion lymphocytes with a huge
population of memory t cells.
Okay.
There are at least five mechanisms that Microbiota can use in causing a skin
disorder.
One is if there is a genetic predisposition in the host,
so there might be a barrier defect or some defect in a regulatory pathway.
Another is an increase in general microbial density that can happen with a
metabolic disease or with something like acne.
Another is a shift in context,
so a pathogen that would cause damage only when the skin barrier is breached.
That would be something like a staphylococcus aureus or Candida Albicans.
They're living there on the skin most of the time and they aren't causing us any
problem unless there's a break in the barrier.
Yeah.
Other pathogens can infect and open a pathway for our skin microbiota to get
through.
And there can also be increases of defined bacteria.
So for example,
staff,
Oreos can increase,
uh,
particularly if it's a multiplier resistant.
Staph Auria is,
so psoriasis,
dermatitis and acne are all diseases that result from disturbance of the skin
ecosystem.
It's a complex ecosystem,
normally managed by crosstalk with the immune system.
Now extrinsic and intrinsic very islands are concepts that crop up in this
context as well.
Many pathogens are harmless in their normal hosts,
but highly,
very Linton accidental hosts.
These are the spillover ones.
Yeah,
there are variances.
Extrinsic because it depends on the environment in which they find themselves.
In contrast to that intrinsic very lens is defined by the position,
by the pathogen of genes that make it more virulent in the naive host.
Then related microbes that lack those jeans.
Okay,
so a good example would be the genes that mediate the production of the toxins
that cause either diptheria or tetanus.
So here is a painting of a person who is having a tea,
a tetanus convulsion,
and is absolutely rigid.
Yeah.
Extrinsic and intrinsic virulence are often difficult to separate.
They are the best analyzed in cases like myxomatosis.
We saw the virus infecting Australian rabbits in which scientists can set aside
both the virus and the rabbit and thereby study changes in host and in pathogen
in a controlled comparative fashion.
Resistance and tolerance in the host are also critical.
Pathogens can evolve to be less virulent,
but host can also evolve to be more tolerant or more resistant.
Both are often happening at the same time.
Either way,
a symbiotic relationship can be established,
so a destructive relationship can be potentially converted into a non
destructive relationship.
By evolution.
However,
the resulting intrinsic variants of the symbiosis is very different in these two
cases,
and it has important consequences for naive hosts who lack that co-evolutionary
history.
These consequences played out dramatically in the introduction of render pissed
from Eurasia to Africa.
So we're now going to take a look at a case in which an entire continent was
naive.
This is a,
this is an infected piece of tissue that has rendered pissed in it.
This is a pathogen that was native to the Eurasian continent and was introduced
to Africa.
It's a virus.
It attacks buffalo cattle,
Eland,
Kudu Giraffe,
Bush book,
warthogs and Bush pigs,
so as attacking ungulates,
it's endemic to the Asian steps and it was repeatedly introduced to Europe
through human invasions where it did cause some problems.
It entered Italian Somali land either in cattle imported from Asia in 1889 or in
Russian cattle with the relief of General Gordon in Khartoum in 1884 so late
19th century
by 1890 it crossed the Sahara and it spread into populations that had no evolved
resistance.
Yeah,
there were some direct consequences.
It's spread over eastern central and southern Africa between 1890 and 1899
they're eliminated most domestic cattle and wild buffalo and many of the related
bovines.
One species of antelope went extinct and the distributions of the other species
remain altered.
To this day.
The pastoral and nomadic peoples lost their food sources and then under the
stress of starvation,
the human population suffered an outbreak of endemic smallpox.
Yeah.
There were subsequent epizootic in 1917 and 18 and 1923 and in 1938 to 41
there were also indirect consequences over much of that infected area at CT
flies disappeared after the epidemic because the population's wild ungulates on
whose blood they fed had been killed by render pissed.
Okay.
Those flies required trees and bushes is their habitat and those herbivores for
their food.
The disappearance of game because the appearance of man eating lions and Uganda.
In the 1920s there was a lion that killed 84 people.
It was starving because render pest had killed it's natural prey and the
presence of man eating lions caused the farmers to abandon large areas in which
thickets of brush then grew up.
The wild ungulates developed immunity to render pest move back into the
abandoned farming areas where they became host for the CT flies.
The CT flies could now live in the new thickets of brush and on the wild
ambulance
because the CT flies transmit sleeping sickness.
The human population then withdrew further and remained absent even after the
lions had switched back to eating ungulates.
So the humans avoided those areas because sleeping sickness is an extremely
serious illness.
Some of those areas then became the national parks of East Africa.
Yeah.
So to summarize,
render pissed,
it changed the ecological structure of half a continent for at least a century.
Okay.
The consequences for humans were drastic.
They were often indirect and they were predictable only in retrospect
it did.
The African ungulates what measles and smallpox did,
the new world humans,
when they were introduced by European colonists,
and it has fortunately recently been eliminated by a vaccination campaign.
However,
it gives you some idea of what happens when a pathogen can encounter immune
systems that have not coevolved with it.
Yeah.
So to summarize,
the immune system,
not only defense against pathogens,
it helps to manage the microbiome
long co-evolutionary interactions between humans and their microbiota has
produced precise physiological mechanisms that foster a symbiotic relationship.
Okay.
Very Lens is the product of a host pathogen interaction that has components
contributed by both the host and by the pathogen.
We see the consequences of host pathogen coevolution most clearly when they have
not occurred,
and that was the case with render pissed in Africa a complete disaster.